um
so tonight we're gonna go on a journey
through space and time
uh all the way from
the land of canaan
uh to the south pole
to chile and beyond i will give an
overview of what the torah
says about cosmology if we can
endeavor to ask such a question and how
the torah relates to science in general
i'll have a little explication of
something that really resonates with me
passages in the torah
that i find particularly
brilliant and full of wisdom
and and then i'll conclude with some
homework i'll actually start with some
homework too so
so let me share my screen and there'll
be questions at the end and you're
welcome to to ask them in the chat room
as well as i'm holding them to the end
i'll do the q a itself
um and i want to welcome my friends on
the east coast to see a bunch of you out
there on the east coast thank you for
staying up late and hopefully it'll be
worth it
but as you know we astronomers we do it
in the dark
we're used to staying up all night and
and then sleeping during the day so
hopefully you'll get a little taste of
what life is like for a professional
astronomer
so i call this if you can count the
stars and i get the reason why that'll
become apparent hopefully
in just a little bit and that'll be kind
of the theme
and it will relate to this project that
i've been involved with for the last
couple of years which i call into the
impossible
which is to try to
test as sir arthur c clarke the namesake
of the center at ucsd that i am
associate director of we aim to push the
boundaries of the possible by seeing the
limits of going into the impossible and
we're going to see that that is a
mission as old as our people as our
history
and hopefully that become clear as we go
on so let me know if you cannot see my
slides the first slide is actually just
an outline just like you're used to from
your college days if you're
one of my older students joining in
tonight from around the world or if
you're a young student you'll know the
rubric
we're going to talk very quickly about
cosmology from two different
perspectives the perspectives of an
astrophysicist
and
the perspective of a torah
observant torah so a different kind of
observer and what they reveal what they
have in common more they differ and how
do you reconcile when one seems to be in
conflict with another i think that's
very very crucial uh for for modern
people to confront
uh because as it is said the signature
of god is truth so if something isn't
true
then it can't really be found to be
resonant with these notions of of
eternal truth and and perhaps ultimate
truth
i'm going to talk a little bit about my
jewish journey which will take us around
the planet
and and maybe beyond and then i'm going
to have some
interesting confluences between
the study of what we do
in cosmology and also something that the
torah speaks about at great length which
is the most humble substance in the
world dust
and and hopefully we'll see a delightful
connection between those
and then a simple question if we have
time you know i'll ask if science can
prove god
that's the question i get second most
first most question is you know how can
you be a scientist and believe
in in god in the torah and then the
second most frequent question i get is
can science prove
god's existence
so let's uh start with some homework so
if you're watching this uh you can do
some homework even though i don't allow
my students in my class to take out
their phones during a lecture if you're
watching it on a computer you can take
out your phone point the camera at that
strange alien typography that little qr
code it'll take you to join my mailing
list
which will keep you apprised of things
all around the universe you have 5 000
people around the planet
that are members and i send out
interesting fun factoids tidbits useful
tools tricks and
brain teasers throughout the month only
once or twice a month do i send
something out so i won't clog up your
spam box
and that wouldn't be right for me to do
and i'll keep you apprised of giveaways
and fun things i do
to keep people really engaged because i
believe my mission as a publicly funded
scientist and all scientists are
publicly funded there's no such thing as
someone who wasn't supported by
the government and therefore by the
taxpayers i believe we have a moral
obligation that's right a moral
obligation to give back to teach to
share what we learned based on your tax
dollars so if you are a taxpayer
and uh and i assume all of us are
we should uh we should pay back the debt
that we owe to you as scientists so
apart i do that through my email list
and the other way i do it is through my
weekly videos that i post with
conversations ranging from nobel prize
winners to astronauts on the space
station traveling at 17 000 miles per
hour
i've had the honor to interview both and
uh and it's really a lot of fun and i do
kind of explainer videos and my mission
is to
maintain curiosity because curiosity is
more important in my mind than passion
passion kind of comes and goes don't
follow your passion follow your
curiosity it will always be there for
you so you can
click your camera go to that
weird code on the upper right and it
should take you to uh to sign up for my
channel you can subscribe to my channel
i see many of you are doing this
homework in real time i love it
so that is wonderful and or you could
just go to youtube and type in my name
okay that's the homework
so now
we come to the beginning
and in the beginning of this webinar
there was a book that book is called
genesis
and today we're going to be talking
about the description that you see in
front of you
this is from i believe the king james
version perhaps some people call it the
bible some people call it
the torah some people call it the old
testament i don't care what you call it
but we're going to talk about the
the statements that are made here
where it says in the beginning
god created the heaven and the earth
and then it goes into much more
description over the course of the
remaining six days of the week the first
week of creation which in some
characterizations in the
bishop
usher
so forth characterized this is occurring
uh in the year 4000 approximately and
what we would now call bce before the
common error before christ if it's uh
using bc
and so uh we're now six thousand years
approximately later and the question is
how do you reconcile this kind of
disruption this kind of depiction
of a finite and really not that long
period of time compared to the
scientific explanation which we all
learned about
when we study the big bang theory
so we're all experts in the big bang
theory um most popular television show
of all time according to some
and it features a character named
sheldon by the way he's based on a real
guy
who i had the honor of interviewing
sheldon glashow winner of the 1979 nobel
prize shared it with somebody i'm going
to talk about steven weinberg renowned
another jewish famous jewish atheist
i didn't have steven weinberg on my uh
podcast unfortunately he's now passed
away but sheldon is based on this real
you know really incredible intellect
named sheldon glashau
and so these nobel prize winners carry
great resonance throughout our culture
and of course
there's no more funny and relevant show
than this one for most cosmologists
so i want to take us on a depiction
of three verses which we'll come back to
frequently throughout this discussion
and it involves these three quotes
involved the following three substances
dust
sand
and stars
and the title of the talk or some title
of the talk no it was a title of the
talk
said um
quoting from genesis uh
chapter 15
it said god took abraham him as abraham
or abram he was known as a brahm
and he said
look up into the sky
and count the stars
count them if you can
that's how many descendants you will
have and this was talking to i believe a
90 year old person rabbi artel will hit
me later on
if i'm wrong but about approximately 90
years old was abram at this time he had
no kids
and let alone did he have
this
huge number of kids
and there was no prospect of this with
his wife sarah who was i believe 80
something at the time
of them ever having kids let alone such
numerous profligate um
expansion of their own personal
universes
so we'll come back to that particular
quote
there's another quote
that involves dust and we'll talk about
that one as well i will make your
offspring like the dust of the earth so
that if one could count the dust of the
earth then your offspring could be
counted
and then lastly it says i shall surely
bless you and i'll multiply you like the
stars in the sky all right he already
said that
hashem you're being kind of repetitive
here
but then it says like the sand on the
seashore so we have three different
metaphors comparisons
that god is saying and promising to
abram abram who will later become
abraham the father of all the
monotheistic religions judaism
christianity and islam and and here he
is saying these three different
comparisons what do they have to do with
each other why use such metaphors and
what do they have to do with modern
cosmology so let's let's turn to the
biblical description of genesis first
so um it's interesting to note there are
six days of creation depicted where god
makes different things
and most of the time he's making stuff
he's not only he's not making something
in a void he's making something and a
comparison something and it's opposite
something and something to complement it
for example he makes adam but he also
makes eve from adam
and that involves dust as you know as
well uh we'll get to that later on he
makes
water he makes light and there's
difference between darkness and light so
there's all these comparisons day and
night
so everything is done in comparison to
something else so this is a nice wood
cut or depiction
colorized by photoshop
in 1493
and it depicts the six days of creation
in in some fashion
sort of from an outside observer maybe
it's god's perspective
god starts off with creating the waters
the upper waters the lower waters we'll
go through that in just a second
what was actually created but note that
it's counting from the top so it goes
one two three four and the fourth day is
on the lower left and that becomes
yellow in the background and that's
because the fourth day
is the day in which the sun is created
so wait you may think well that's kind
of weird how do you have a day
which we define as a 24-hour period how
do you find a day or an hour
when the sun hasn't been created until
the fourth day what is that meant to
teach us
it must be telling us something
obviously people knew that day was
caused by sun
night was caused by the absence of sun
that there was there were other
luminaries in the sky the moon
the stars they knew that even if you
want to say they didn't know cosmology
they didn't know have the benefit of the
hubble space telescope
they still knew that day followed night
because of the repetition of the daily
cyclical pattern of the sun rising from
our perspective and setting each day
so how could you have a day without the
sun it must be coming to tell us
something something very interesting and
i'll skip to the punch line in that
context for me not as a cosmologist but
as as just a person who is comfortable
with basic logic that it came to teach
us something that that even the sun and
moon which were
throughout history have been worshipped
as deities
that they were created so it was
unambiguous that the earth
and the and the sun and the moon were
not gods
say what you will if you believe it or
not if it was literal or not
nevertheless
you have to agree that the time that the
perspective that's being depicted
is obviously one that's showing a
creation
of things previously considered to be
gods
the sun and the moon and the stars
so this is this was rampant throughout
the middle east and throughout history
that those were worshiped and then later
on things like trees and and herbs and
so forth were created but even it says
that you weren't able to see the light
from the sun
until that that very special fifth day
in the middle lower panel and then later
the culmination of all of creation
according to the biblical sources was
the creation of man or humans
man and woman were created as it says
so what i think is so interesting is
that people come up to me and they say
oh professor keating how can you believe
in this you know it's like uh the torah
and and judaism and and so forth are
incompatible with science and i say to
them imagine you picked up a book
and in that book
um were it was a thousand page book and
in that book there were 999 pages and
they were dedicated to the history
and the background behind the national
basketball association okay there's a
book and 99.9 of it is about the nba
and then there's one page and there's
one page and it's about the american
revolutionary war
and then you say okay well that's kind
of weird i don't know what they really
have to do with each other maybe nba
started america it was american who
knows but
okay so it's in there maybe it's
relevant in some way then you turn the
cover over you look at the cover and
says the history of of the american
revolution
you'd say this is very weird like this
book is it has a little bit of that in
it but the most 99.9 of it is not about
that well guess what
that's the exact ratio of verses
that cover these six days
there's 35 verses
in the torah in genesis about these
events
and there's 35 000 total verses in the
five books of moses the old testament
the bible whatever you want to call it
so it's the same it's the same 0.1
percent
so to me again just from basic logic
you have to agree that the torah is not
coming to teach us about science and in
fact torah translates to wisdom
and and teaching
but the word science comes from latin
cientia and that means knowledge and
there's a very big difference between
knowledge and wisdom as the saying goes
knowledge is knowing a tomato is a fruit
but wisdom is knowing not to put it in a
fruit salad
and i think when we look at this
chronology
it's not meant to teach us about
about
genetics evolution cosmology and so
forth so many of you may be feeling like
maybe you should tune out now i hope you
won't but the point is we have a
depiction that's coming to teach us
something perhaps about wisdom not
necessarily about the knowledge of the
physical universe and nor should we go
there to glean information about physics
you know if i'm teaching i am teaching
cosmology this this quarter and one of
my students you know tells me that
they're
you know they they don't believe that
the universe is expanding because it's
not in the torah i'd say well you know
you're free it's a free country but uh
but that's not
accurate to describe it as part of
modern cosmology in fact we're going to
go through some of the competing
cosmologies that the torah supplanted
uniquely so for thousands of years again
i'm not going to use that as proof that
the torah is correct that god definitely
exists or that science somehow backs up
the torah description as some people
have claimed it does i don't believe
that's possible because i don't believe
that's a mission of the torah and yet i
believe the torah is the most important
book ever read i've written three books
well i've written two books and i've
recorded a third book
an audio only book and when they all
start off they're kind of it's nice to
see a book you know it goes to you know
high ranking on amazon and you can get
your author ranking on amazon
and then within a couple of days it
falls off and it goes down to almost
zero i mean it goes down to like
1 million or something like that out of
the 10 million books on amazon so you
feel a little dejected but it's natural
that's what happens except if your name
is you know hashem or god and you wrote
a book called the bible and that just
kind of like stays at number one for all
time and so what did the torah have to
do and how to do something that neither
one of my written books or nor my audio
book can do
which is to speak to people thousands of
years ago
and
continue to speak to people for
thousands of years to come that's
something that only wisdom can do i hope
that my books
are superseded and rendered obsolete by
discoveries that i make or my colleagues
and my students make
i hope the works of stephen hawking are
completely obsolete and any good
scientist should say that they hope that
their work is superseded because that's
the way that science makes progress
and we'll explain why in just a bit so
there's a depiction i'm not going to
talk too much about it
how it's depicted it's certainly not how
we understand how the universe how the
earth is shaped or so forth again we
have to ask go deeper and talk about
what is it trying to teach us
what is it trying to do is it trying to
really understand the scientific method
that wouldn't be invented until the late
six middle 1600s by galileo or is it
doing something different and if so what
and and where does it establish its
expertise obviously modern cosmologists
like myself and others have expertise in
our domain the question is when you get
into trouble is when you try to shoehorn
or force one into the other domain and i
can hear arguments on both sides that
say the tor should contain all this
wisdom and truth and some that would say
it has nothing to teach us so it's a
careful line to walk but i think that's
the most fun challenging and interesting
way to approach this immense book of
wisdom that we call the the old
testament of the bible
so how does that depiction of the first
six days what how does it relate or what
is it to be compared to it really is
compared to a theory called that we call
the big bang theory
which posits that the universe came into
existence x nilio from nothing
which actually sounds very similar to
the bible's description the bible
doesn't talk about anything before the
genesis 1 1. it talks about the
beginning establishing a singular
event
before which there were no days or times
perhaps
and after which there was history that
could be recorded and characterized both
in the physical world to a minor extent
0.1 percent extent
and later to understand the evolution of
specific peoples in the near east and
middle east now the big bang theory was
brought about through a series of
scientific observations hypotheses and
the application of the scientific method
and yet it wasn't really verified
uh for many decades and in fact it was
never proven and it still isn't proven
and before you start to object you know
if you're coming to this as a scientist
and saying like even this cosmologist
doesn't believe in the big bang
well that's the whole thing when you
believe in something it means you don't
have evidence for it it means that you
are necessarily if you have faith in
something rather it means you don't have
proof of it or data or evidence and in
science we can't really prove things
we can't do a good job of proving
something that took place once in in the
history of the entire universe namely
the birth of the universe itself
unless
that's not what happened
and i'll explain what i mean in just a
bit
so
if you look on the right side of this
plot here
you see these galaxies and and whatnot
and the galaxies uh that you see
uh will later look like the milky way
galaxy and we'll harbor uh planets and
those planets will have people upon it
in the modern cosmological
interpretation we know of hundreds of
billions of galaxies we know of billions
of stars that are in each galaxy and we
know that inside around each star there
are perhaps tens or thousands of planets
and asteroids and comets just like our
solar system harbors and in fact there's
so many stars that are just like the sun
that have planets just like the earth
within them that we've almost stopped
counting them and now we're trying to
learn more and more about their
properties in the hope
some say vain hope i'm not going to talk
about that now although i've expressed
it on other people's podcast
that that they will find life and
perhaps even intelligent life on other
planets around other stars in our galaxy
and perhaps in other galaxies in the
universe
so again what is abraham commanded to do
it says go out and count the stars
again rabbi or tong
correct me
um it's in a command form it's saying go
and count the stars and then it says if
you can
and if you can do that then that is what
your offspring will be numbered
um so here's an image of a
host of of pixels of light
and
every single smudge
from this picture taken by the hubble
space telescope about 25 years ago
every single smudge of light every speck
of light with one exception
is a galaxy
so there's only one
star in this whole picture that stars in
the just below the word the
and it has this kind of cross-like
pattern double cross pattern
that's the only star that stars in the
milky way galaxy and every other speck
of light is a galaxy outside of the
milky way galaxy potentially just like
the milky way galaxy
harboring perhaps a hundred billion or a
trillion stars in each galaxy
so how could you count the stars
well we'll come back to that in just a
bit
so i said scientists
don't go about talking about things they
have faith in or they believe in
and the hebrew term is a muna from which
we get the word in english amen meaning
truth
but that's a statement of faith we don't
i don't have faith that gravity is going
to cause this uh object to fall
i have evidence for that and we have a
superseding theory that explains based
on observational data
through the rigorous process of
refinement that we call the scientific
method
that that behavior will be replicated
but it is
possible in some circumstances
for something that has been observed in
the past to no longer behave that way in
the future
that effectively there are forces in the
universe that behave like anti-gravity
and in fact one of them was established
by albert einstein himself about a
hundred years ago a type of
anti-gravitation a type of
anti-repulsive gravitation
which was totally in contradistinction
to anything ever conceived of before
and the reason he conjectured that
was to adhere to his world view of how
the cosmos must behave
that he believed we lived not in a
universe with a singular big bang origin
but an ecstatic universe
and we're going to talk about that but
the
statement of what scientists do or do
not do
we don't really prove things we
typically will prove things wrong we
won't prove things right
i can't
necessarily prove to you that there is
right now a purple unicorn on the north
pole of neptune
we cannot physically do that
you could disprove it if you could go
there and so forth and see it but you
can't prove
and have any physical evidence
instantaneously that that's there right
now so you can't prove or you can't
prove something happened if it only
happened once
in the course of of history
so what this philosopher carl popper
said is that you shouldn't look to prove
things you should look to disprove
everything else and what will be left is
the closest approximation to the truth
for example
many of us know for certain the earth is
not flat
but very few of us know that the earth
is not a perfect sphere either
so both of those statements are wrong if
i say the earth is flat i'm wrong
but i'm somehow more wrong than when i
say the earth is a perfect sphere even
though i'm wrong when i say the earth is
a perfect sphere it's not because of the
rotation of the earth it bulges at the
equators and becomes a little bit like
pear-shaped
and squashed as it rotates so it's not a
perfect sphere either and yet it's more
close to the approximation that's what
scientists should be doing
should look for experiments that come
closer and closer to truth to the
accurate description and then
parameterize what we do not know
so what are some of the alternatives to
the
singular origin of the universe turns
out there's a lot of them i'm not going
to read them all here but one of the
most important ones is called a cyclic
model
and this is artwork from about a
thousand bc
uh talking about the universe as cycling
through time from an egyptian book of
the dead
and this again the jews had no
lack of familiarity with with egyptian
texts in egyptian knowledge the torah is
a tree of life their book was a book of
death
their god was the sun god to the jews
the jews
said that hashem that god created the
sun so how could it be a god there's a
lot of counterpose and not of
counterpoint between
egyptian culture and uh and the hebraic
culture
but nowadays we still have colleagues
and friends and working on my project
called the simon's observatory
that are working on a type of cyclic
cosmology where the universe cycles
through endless periods of expansion and
contraction over uncountable eons of
time
and and this occurs with the same
dynamics that we would observe and this
stands in contradistinction to a single
universe a universe that's infinite in
time
is not created at a point at which
an author be it god moses whoever could
say
was the beginning it
loses meaning if it's a periodic cyclic
universe therefore if you could prove
this model is wrong
you would come some way to establishing
some more credulity in the big bang
torah description if you will of a
single event that had a single beginning
there were no shortage of other
cosmologies that weren't uh that weren't
dynamic like that previous one there was
one by aristotle the universe was static
fixed in size unchanging for all time
uh newton came along 2 000 years later
with a steady state static universe in
which he had to posit an unstable
universe
that was somehow magically kept at bay
from gravitational instability and
collapsed
this mode was then built upon by albert
einstein
worked on yitzhak newton's laws
improved them came up with a new theory
of gravity that incorporated an
anti-gravitational force
to keep the universe
opposed to the contraction that would
surely result from the newtonian
description
turned out he was wrong
about the philosophical underpinning of
this term which he called the
cosmological constant
but later about 80 years later we did
measure that the universe not only has a
cosmological constant but it's causing
the universe to get bigger in its size
and its rate of expansion with every
passing second for all time
and that's called cosmic acceleration
now some of these models were
were appealing
especially to atheists
like the late great stephen weinberg who
as i mentioned passed away
shared the nobel prize with old sheldon
sheldon cooper
uh the character b in which he's based
on sheldon glashow he said the steady
state theory
is philosophically the most attractive
theory because at least resembles the
account given in genesis in other words
this atheist happens to be born you know
jewish but atheist scientist is saying
that what makes
the steady state model which is an uh
and an antithetical concept to the big
bang theory it posits the universe has
been around forever
he's saying that's attractive because it
doesn't
involve anything to do that could be
correlated with religion as does the big
bang model it's pretty amazing
and so even though hubble had evidence
that the universe was expanding and was
dynamic it really took until the 1960s
until there were theoretical predictions
as well as experimental observations
including the subject that i study
called the cosmic microwave background
or cmb
that supported the fact that the
universe began or was at one point
incredibly hot and dense
sufficiently so to cause nuclear
reactions to fuse lighter elements into
heavier elements producing the periodic
table
left upper hand entries
and that was a decisive blow against the
steady state model
it doesn't prove the big bang but again
that's not what scientists do we're not
in the job of trying to prove something
happen we're trying to essentially
disprove any other alternative and then
the preponderance of evidence occam's
razor if you will will suggest that the
most likely result lies outside of those
disproven alternatives and will be
corroborated by evidence sometimes
circumstantial of things like the big
bang
now many people throughout history have
picked up on the corollary between
the genesis 1 1 description
and the observations both of hubble
and of
the cosmic microwave background in the
1960s
in particular one who was an uh agnostic
robert jastrow
he wrote in a book called god in the
astronomers
he wrote the scientists who's lived by
faith
meaning that like the weinberg type
scientist who had been hoping that the
big bang was wrong because it was too
theistic in its application
he said that story ends like a bad dream
he scaled the mountains of ignorance
he's about to conquer the highest peak
pulls himself over the final rock he's
greeted by a band of theologians who
have been sitting there for centuries
meaning that the evidence for the cosmic
microwave background just like hubble's
evidence
seemed to be suggestive of and was used
by theistic proponents namely the pope
uh popeyes in the
1930s and 40s took upon the work of
hubble to say that this proved there was
an origin of the universe just like in
genesis then this guy jastrow saying a
similar thing 30 to 40 years later based
on completely different evidence and
that's what you want as a scientist you
want multiple
types of evidence pointing to a singular
explanation
that all agree and build consensus
that's what we and scientists do we
can't say a hundred percent that
anything that evolution is occurring
that um that global warming is occurring
but you can have a preponderance of
evidence for multiple disparate fields
that will allow scientists to build
powerful consensus though admitting we
can never prove unequivocally something
is true or correct or definitive
so again modern cosmology history starts
with a big bang on the left
and then produces a cosmic microwave
background
that's what i study
and what i did
along with some colleagues is create an
experiment that effectively was trying
to refute
if you will alternatives to the big bang
hypothesis
which would be uh if we were to be
successful with this experiment called
bicep 2 we would measure the aftershocks
of the big bang
it's as close as you could get to taking
an infant baby picture of the newborn
embryonic universe
so um
i've said most of this the torah
description versus the scientific
description
people like karen mentioned this at
gerald schroeder i happen to have
violent disagreements with him about a
lot of stuff
and nevertheless there are people that
try to shoehorn in
to the six days of creation
a literal phenomenon of passage of time
corresponding to each uh situational
event that's taken place only a tiny bit
of which is actually indicated on the
plots on the left so the plot on the
left is showing time after the big bang
in seconds and then years and then
leading up to the 1990s when some of us
were born or alive and it's trying to
then shoehorn in the elapsed time
according to the cosmology of of these
different events
i'm not going to get into that i i've
spoken about that elsewhere but but this
is a very very uh fraught process to try
to do
because as uh some of these processes
depend very sensitively on the
conditions of preceding epochs
and uh and it's it's essentially
impossible to make uh definitive
predictions as the universe becomes more
and more well understood the uh the
tension between
the six days of creation in this uh
translation by schroeder and others
becomes more and more uh excluded so i'm
gonna get into that uh that's not
something i'm particularly interested in
discussing here other than the fact that
again i'm trying to say that the torah
is not a science book and so i take
issue even with my fellow scientists
who happen to be jewish
i had to take great issue when that is
trying to make this torah into a science
book because then you could get into a
situation where if the torah says
something so there's a there's an
elementary particle called the uh called
the crouton uh then and we never
discover it and somehow it's listed in
the torah as being uh evidence on which
the big bang theory of the torah rest
then the disproof of that would
therefore
bring up questions of the ultimate
veracity of the torah itself so these
are very fraud things to do i personally
don't like it you're free to go and
explore it and read it uh be my guest
but i personally don't think it's a a
fruitful way to proceed but let's get
back to this description can we
reconcile these two things
my claim is that is a very very tenuous
process indeed and i don't think it's a
necessary process
i don't think it's necessary to shoehorn
in
the 13.8 billion years and notice that
change is pretty radical it's 2 billion
years difference from the schroeder
calculations that's a 25 error
in your logic as a
as a scientist or accuracy as a
scientist so i see uh there's something
in the chat i cannot read the chat until
unless they stop the presentation which
i don't want to do but if something's
super urgent um and maybe andy you could
let me know
if i'm like
you guys have not heard anything i've
said for last 20 minutes let me know
andy you're still all good everything's
good
great
so
um we can't prove things
we can falsify things can we falsify
what the torah says
so that's a scientific question it's not
a theistic question or theological
question
so the torah says there was a beginning
science says there may have been a
beginning this is from someone else's
slide a frying pal of knob i don't know
how to pronounce his name um but um but
again these are trying to make a
correspondence between
between
a biblical description and hebrew words
and then trying to convert those into
modern scientific language
uh and at any point in history
this could have been done
the
and there would have been zero evidence
for a singular beginning in isaac
newton's time and uh early part of
einstein's career there would have been
no evidence for it so the torah in some
sense is going out on a limb by saying
that there was a singular event
so we can ask the question can you prove
that there are multiple events
can you disprove that there are multiple
e multiple creation type events
if you could somehow prove that there
were multiple e-creation events that
would call into question some aspects of
the torah's veracity and as a scientific
book not as a book of wisdom which i
claim is its uh primary contribution
i think anybody who goes and studies
science and uses the torah
as their reference material is going to
experience a great deal of challenges
so you see here in both of these it says
that science believes there's a period
of rapid inflation and that says the
torah says there's rapid inflation i'd
never seen the word inflation before
inflation has a very very specific
meaning that means acceleration
faster than light and the early universe
there's no mention of that to my
knowledge nor by even claim by
someone like gerald schroeder who i
disagree with in many cases nevertheless
it behooves us to ask the question was
there a singular point a singularity an
origin and again this is something
that's also untrue on the left column
there was no there's no consensus
there's no proof that science says there
was a singularity a singularity is a a
not just an event that occurred once it
has a very specific meaning in that you
have infinite density curvature
temperature of space and time at a at a
finite point in time
and we have no proof of that no evidence
of that and uh and yet that we can
observe the after effects if it did
occur we can ask is the evidence that we
see consistent
with a singular origin or a very high
temperature origin
so now we're going to do a little
travelogue
not going back billions of years just
going back about 50 years
my wanderings through the desert of this
world and the places that i've been so i
grew up
on long island and i was a jew so at
that point i was a jew it's gonna be a
little complicated because you're gonna
see i go through more cycles than a
cyclic universe i start off parents both
jewish born to biological jewish parents
uh grew up on long island for the first
seven years parents got divorced
um i used to love looking at the moon
and uh i moved in and lived with my
stepfather who was a devout irish
catholic
with
nine brothers and sisters
and was actually converted to
catholicism i had a communion i had a
um i had a confirmation
i had my
baptism all at age
12 to 13
when i
would have been preparing for my bar
mitzvah
as a typical jewish boy had my
parents not gotten divorced and had i
remained in the faith and it's funny
because i'm like one of my kids my
oldest son yeah he's a couple years away
from his bar mitzvah and he will say
things to me like you know i say you
have to fast
on yom kippur soon and he's like but
it's not my bar mitzvah and i'm not
obligated to fast until my bar mitzvah
uh a couple years and then i said well i
haven't had my bar mitzvah either so
maybe i don't have to fast on yom kippur
so i never had a bar mitzvah don't weep
any tears for me i've received
tremendous blessings even despite that
lack in my life and my goal is to to
actually
have my bar mitzvah someday
perhaps even in israel on my fourth bar
mitzvah anniversary when i'm 52. so stay
tuned for news about that on my mailing
list
um so i was an altar boy so i wanted to
do everything you could possibly do i'm
a very kind of purist i always want to
do things the most authentic way
possible so i want to be a priest
and um and again i was 12 at this time
and the closest thing you could do it as
a 12 year old is become an altar boy and
so at that church called the church of
saint john and saint mary with the man
on the left with the bishop hat uh was
actually a monsignor father skelly
robert scally and he was a wonderful man
and he uh you know was a great religious
thinker a great
a humorous uh soul incredible gift for
uh being with people and i just had a
delightful time this is in chapaqua new
york
and i uh wanted to be a priest for
maybe a year or two and so i kept kept
it up the altar boy
and then um i got a telescope
on my 13th birthday
and uh between the age of 12 and 13 i
met my first rabbi which i call my rabbi
and that's galileo galilei
who was
really first person that i felt could
communicate with me from beyond the
grave and that he had been departed for
so long and yet his writing his thinking
his uh his artistry he was a wonderful
artist poet musician
all these things wrapped into one which
made me want to be
him and
and so when i got my first telescope i
tried to repeat the observations that he
had made which in some part contributed
in a very strange way i've realized that
um that the telescope has kind of
been an
integral part of
not only the uh the revelation of
beautiful works and and objects and
things in the universe but also of the
maybe the decline of religion and the
way it came about i kind of have this
cartoon from a tweet i put out once
about what happened in the history of
science is that galileo didn't invent
the telescope but he uh he pi he
perfected it he made it into the device
that he could use to do actual science
um and the telescope came from the fact
that people at just in the late 1400s
early 1500s uh been
able to use reading glasses so having
pieces of glass that they could combine
together and in front of their eyes and
that would improve their vision and how
they know they needed glasses they would
look at uh at standard print
font of a certain size printed in uh in
movable typeset printing that was only
invented by the gutenberg bible by
gutenberg himself in the 1400s
so the fact that the first thing ever
printed then became the eyeglass or eye
eyesight standard
it's kind of ironic because then later
the telescope came to overthrow
the church
belief that the earth was the center of
the universe
and that led to all sorts of things like
secularism and humanism and
ultimately the decline of religion
itself it was kind of ironic that the
bible was kind of responsible for its
own decline
but that's not really the subject of
this discussion
it's mark galileo and what he saw
through this telescope and what he wrote
in his book the cedirius nuncius and
later in the dialogue which i've just
published as an audiobook with about six
of my physicist friends the first ever
audiobook by galileo galilei so i have
two
written books and one
audio only book
and what galileo did is he went on a
book tour and he tried to sell copies
you see in his in his right hand he's
holding pictures of sketches and stuff
and he's showing it to these senators in
venice and they want to buy the
telescope and so forth and he became
incredibly famous like like this person
here
uh he had you know 100 million twitter
followers now the equivalent of it he
became he never left italy and people as
far away as asia knew about him in his
own lifetime it's really quite
incredible
and of course what he did is usher in
this notion that the universe is not
centered on the earth it's centered on
the sun
and that got him into great trouble with
the inquisition because the inquisition
for bad the teaching
of copernicanism of heliocentrism
and saying in my opinion in a wrong
interpretation of of the hebrew
apparently allegedly from the book of
joshua
that that joshua
caused the sun to stand still or hashem
god caused that to
stop rotating around the earth and for
that
apparently that was one of the main
sources
of the sun being in orbit around the
earth as shown on the left and of course
we know that's wrong today
and in between when galileo was about to
be persecuted he thought he could get
away with it because in his book the
dialogue is my friends and i read it as
a dramatic work of of literature he says
in it basically it's like a proof of
god's existence that god can make
whatever he wants and so he said here i
do not feel obligated to believe that
the same god who has endowed us with
sense
reason and intellect has intended
us to forego their use
and he also said the bible teaches us
how to go to heaven not how the heavens
go
so he was a
he tested the waters back then and don't
forget only 11 years before he wrote his
book
giordano bruno was burned at the stake
so galileo got off kind of easily he was
house imprisoned
courtesy of the inquisition the holy
office as it was called there he is
about to get hit with this conquistador
sword
but he was sentenced to prison his
prison is this villa outside of florence
where i was pleased to host a conference
in his honor about seven years ago
he still has
olive trees and grapevines it's a pretty
nice prison i think bernie madoff would
have been happy there um but uh but
nevertheless he was uh he was imprisoned
and threatened with possible torture he
was actually never tortured but there
were threats about it
so after that
uh period of time after learning that
galileo had never been pardoned for the
sin of suspicion of heresy
that the earth was the
no longer the center of the universe
i became disenchanted with religion i
thought any
religion that would persecute
my hero wasn't worthy of me being a part
of so actually left the catholic church
and completely lost my religion
and was an atheist for many many years
from the time
of uh you know early high school till
graduate school
and beyond
and i kind of used uh this this
deduction which was that you know
galileo was never pardoned he was never
forgiven
for what he did even
up until the time of the discovery of
the cosmic microwave background he's
actually never formally been pardoned
he was ruled correct by pope john paul
the great pope john paul in the 1980s
but that was uh that was long after i
was uh kind of disenchanted with the
catholic church
so i i kind of abandoned my faith and i
said well
to myself well judaism you know was
around before christianity and if i have
problems with christianity
and it came along after judaism well
christianity must have fixed all the
flaws in judaism and and updated those
and there's a lot of similarities
between uh judaism and christianity but
there's a lot that christianity
overthrew in judaism so it's very
different
and so that that logical syllogism as
it's called deductive argument is not
really a
kosher form of inference and yet that's
kind of the way my my mind was working
back then and eventually after
graduation from brown i went to stanford
as a what's called a post stock and i
had ideas to test whether or not the big
bang actually occurred
ideas for a telescope there was just one
problem
i wasn't being paid to do that
i was being paid to work on a completely
different project and so my advisor
um by the way if anyone knows this this
german they know that the motto of
stanford is de lufte frijaduet which
means the wind of freedom blows and i
was blown free of a paycheck
um very shortly after uh being
at stanford and i was actually fired by
a professor whose name is church
so i got in trouble with the church too
very different than galileo of course
but it did involve a refracting
telescope just like what galileo built
and i'm not comparing myself to galileo
or to the fate of suffering at the hands
of the church
from there i went to caltech a small
technical college in los angeles
and about a year after i got there 911
occurred
and again at this point i had really not
i had not been jewish for you know
practicing observant doing anything uh
for 20 30 years
and yet when 9 11 occurred it became
increasingly clear to me that there was
uh something about judaism that i didn't
know it was kind of
gnawing at me that i knew so much about
islam and it was it was kind of you know
perhaps unfairly being tarnished in some
ways in the media but everybody knew
about islam and what it stands for and
what is it a religion about
i knew a lot about christianity
and catholicism because of my
peripatetic upbringing but i knew
nothing about the religion i was born
into
so that was kind of when i resolved to
start learning
about judaism and i actually started
teaching myself to read hebrew and i
studied with a rabbi and i went to
israel
and i studied in shiva for a month
and i vowed to try to
establish
descendants to have children to have a
jewish
family and to bring up kids um according
to the religion of my birth that had
increasingly appealed to me
and i saw it as sort of
not
in an ethnic sense but actually in a
an almost a moral philosophical sense
that i had been given
a a history a legacy that was very
precious and i want to know more about
it and if it was valuable to me i felt
that i could use its wisdom of
generations of millennia after all
to better my life and to break out of
the cycle of divorce you know
despondency depression
anger etc that had driven my family
apart of course nothing is a cure-all
uh for those things but
nevertheless it offered some hope and uh
and in that sense especially the
the
ability of the torah to speak to the
dynamics of families don't forget you
know abraham uh you know it doesn't get
pregnant uh sarah sarah doesn't get
pregnant until she's 90 or so
they all they have children that fight
with each other of course uh jacob and
asa fight and want to kill each other
joseph and his brother so the torah is
very true to what life is like i mean
nobody has a hopefully you know families
where your brother's trying to kill you
um cain and abel
uh but nevertheless uh it speaks
in very realistic terms about the
limitations
of the
uh of the human condition and that
appealed to me it wasn't uh
it wasn't aspirational that i couldn't
ever achieve it wasn't far from me it
was something i could become and uh i
felt a great appeal to it and so i
started out a mission
to see if there were these blessings
and i actually got a blessed to come to
ucsd in 2004 where i've been ever since
18 years i've been here
on the seashore there that abraham was
promised to have sand-like numbers of
offspring so i don't know about that uh
my wife's not down for that but um but
nevertheless it was something that uh
that i knew i had to continue this
mission to try to understand
if i could reconcile some of the aspects
of science with the torah
and so we built this telescope it was
called bicep we took it from san diego
and caltech we took it down to the south
pole antarctica so now i'm traveling
with you to antarctica
we shipped it there it's a refracting
telescope at the bottom of the world
i've been there twice
and it's an otherworldly ice planet uh
like in star wars the planet hoth and
it's been a challenge to get to for a
hundred years more it was only
discovered in the early 1900s the south
pole
and the people in the bottom all died
trying to get back from the south pole
and lost their battle froze to death in
a march of uh of 1912
110 years ago this year
and they did it for kind of the same
nationalistic pride that we went to the
moon or people do stuff as nations
and they were also interested in science
and i thought it's it's an amazing place
to be still very dangerous if you go
there now you're as likely perhaps to
lose your life
not to the cold conditions because you
wear very warm comfortable clothing but
to the fauna that are so violent and so
destructive those are brothers the one
on the on the right is his name is kane
uh but um but maybe they're just mad at
other penguins maybe they get along with
people so i try to get close to one the
second time i went down there is also
extremely dangerous
so
maybe not quite as dangerous as when
scott and company froze to death
but we actually made this discovery that
we were trying to make in other words we
saw the imprint that would have proven
as close as you could beyond a
reasonable doubt that the universe began
with a big bang and that was called a
detection of this inflationary signal
and you see at stanford back where i
used to be
there was a video put out it got three
million views in a day or two
there was a press conference at harvard
and i described this in my first book
losing the nobel prize
um
and i kind of send links to folks on my
youtube channel that show this we were
on cnn we were in the uh the most
important newspaper uh in all of the
planet the san diego union tribune you
see that on the left uh and uh and also
on this paper called the new york times
um and uh and i wanted to
really
draw your attention to what it shows in
the middle of that column of the new
york times it says space ripples
seen as the big bang smoking gun so we
had done it this is on
march 17 2014.
on the left you see this very very
wrinkle we detect evidence of such an
event after the big bang i was a little
bit more cautious in that article
and you see something in the top you see
you know history
history keeps rhyming it doesn't repeat
there's putin invading crimea okay so uh
eight years later he's invading ukraine
right and the bottom you see the
economist it sounds like some guy just
saw the beginning of the universe that's
kind of cool
and um and then we were whispered about
winning a nobel prize now spoiler alert
my first book's called losing the nobel
prize to at least you you know i didn't
win it uh but uh perhaps other people
could win it and the question is why why
didn't i win the double prize when
anybody win the nobel prize
so you know you made it when you are
printed up in the onion and you can see
this about uh this quote from below
so these are talking about the meaning
of forever they're talking about the
bicep two experiment this is in a month
after the announcement was made
so that was kind of ticklish to see that
but
everything uh was had to be kind of
evaluated and taken uh with a grain
of dust as it turns out so there are
these this cartoon shows these two
housekeepers whatever in a hotel maybe
looking out
and saying it's so beautiful but i can't
stop thinking about all the interstellar
dust out there now why would they be
thinking about such things well it turns
out the universe is a pretty filthy
place
it's full of failed comets failed
asteroids meteorites
galactic schmutz as we professionals
call it and this dust can actually mimic
the imprimatur of the big bang signal
that we were seeking and in fact it did
and it replicated and fooled us into
believing that the signal that we saw
was actually the harbinger of the early
universe's birth pangs but it wasn't
it was actually the mere presence
of microscopic grains of dust permeating
our galaxy not even the cosmos just our
galaxy
and it tricked us into believing that we
had
detected once and for all the big bang
smoking gun
so now we know the universe isn't so
pristine we can't just look here from
earth all the way back to the beginning
of time
that instead it's kind of smoggy
it's kind of smoky
kind of reminds me of los angeles on a
bad day
the universe has a tons and tons and
tons of this type of substance the very
humble substance but one that we didn't
account for in its completeness and
that's called dust
and so we have to pivot we have to pick
ourselves up and dust ourselves off even
when our nobel aspirations are blown
away into the dust of the wind
we still have to do more and so we have
created a new experiment and it's called
the simon's observatory
and this observatory
has a goal to not only detect these
aftershocks of the big bang if the big
bang occurred
but also to detect the presence of dust
in the universe and get rid of it and
account for it accurately and precisely
using an array of instruments that i
won't talk about in great detail but
here's a couple of beautiful pictures of
our site and i'll show you some data or
some video from our site that we just
got today
so you can follow us online
it's at 17
200 feet above sea level in the atacama
desert of northern chile which is
considered the driest desert on earth
it's called the desert of deserts
i actually thought it was the dessert of
desserts when i went there the first
time i was sorely mistaken but it's on
this plateau
high above sea level
where you can basically look straight up
and feel like you're looking into the
inky blackness of outer space
from there we're attempting to build
courtesy of very very um a generous
funding from both the simons foundation
and the heising-simons foundation and
our member and partner institutions
that are been so generous including um
uc san diego princeton penn and berkeley
that founded the observatory in 2016. we
aimed to be taking data with it in
2022 a 2024 which is just about two
years from now less than two years we
aim to have data from both the
universe's inflationary origin if that
indeed took place
and from dust and potentially
rule out or constrain these other models
of cosmic genesis cyclic universes
bouncing universes static universes we
can rule all those out perhaps there
would be enough credulity in the
existence of inflation
and therefore the single big bang
so again coming back to one of the three
quotes i started with
god said to you abram i will make your
offspring like the dust of the earth
so that if one can count the dust of the
earth then your offspring could be
counted
so again we heard about the stars will
be like
uh the children the offspring now we
hear dust so can we count the dust well
to count dust and cosmology we need to
have very smart people working with us
and these are some of our students just
here at uc san diego
working with us they are right next to
the price centers or student center here
and they're some of the most brilliant
people that i would work with for free
and i can't believe that i get paid to
work with these geniuses we're building
refracting telescopes not unlike one
that galileo himself would recognize to
look back and to get the earliest
evidence not only for the existence of
gravitational waves and the big bang but
perhaps for also at the same time ruling
out competing models for how the
universe could have been formed but
didn't
to do that we have to measure dust and
measure the cmb so we have three
different telescopes and that way we can
count dust as well as count the signals
that we're looking for and we have these
three telescopes here one of which is in
my laboratory
being
completely
built by my colleague professor cam
arnold and our students and postdocs
here and another one at princeton
university
led by lyman page and we have one of my
colleagues on the phone uh fred carl
who's invaluable member of the team
and we also have a
third uh telescope which is being uh
built by my colleague adrian lee and his
group at uc berkeley these three
telescopes will sit on this very strange
looking platform which has this thing
called a call moving shield i only point
that out because we just recently took
uh delivery and here's a time lapse
of just about a day you're going to see
underneath that giant arrow
you're going to see a lot of
construction activity this remind you is
at 17 000 feet above sea level the
atmospheric air pressure is half
that which we feel here at sea level
we have to be continuously on oxygen
there's tremendous danger from
ultraviolet rays uh the incredibly dry
obviously you almost see no clouds at
any time the sky is completely black
when you look overhead and it's a
tremendously alien environment and oh by
the way those little pointy mountains
are volcanoes that we think are dormant
but not extinct and every so often they
erupt so you see those big boxes
underneath that crane so we have to
provide everything cam and others have
built out the site with infrastructure
with concrete with diesel-powered
generators with laboratories in the
foreground getting cranes up to 17 000
feet it's an incredible challenge but we
have an incredible team and i'm so
pleased to be a part of it
all in an effort to measure
simultaneously the cosmic signals that
we care about as well as measuring the
dust signals so i want to conclude
by saying
this famous quote
which we led off with the lord took
abram outside said look up and count the
stars
commanding him to do it he says if you
can that's how many descendants you will
have
now it says that there will be
um previously it said they will be
assert you'll have as many
offspring also as the dust and of the
sand on the seashore so i'm an
astronomer and i wanted to do a
calculation are there more grains of
sand in the earth's beaches
or
are there more stars in the universe or
are they the same number
so it turns out you can go through the
calculation
in the milky way galaxy we know there's
about 100 billion to at most half a
trillion stars we can count them up
and we can do a simple estimation of how
many grains of sand there are and it
comes out to be about 3 billion billion
grains of sand so there's more than a
billion times more about a billion times
more 33 million or so times more grains
of sand on the seashore than there are
uh stars in the sky
and yet
what did abraham do he went out and he
tried to do it
so this is a tour of our galaxy now
imagine trying to count every single
star
in this galaxy uh obviously that's
impossible this is kind of a simulation
of what it would look like we can't get
far enough away to actually do this type
of a journey through the galaxy but
every single point of light is a star
and then there's a lot of dust in there
too of course
so
each star is unique
and as it said
when we try to do the impossible
amazing things often happen it is
through persistence that we discover our
true abilities
so we can't count the number of stars in
the in the sky we couldn't count the
number of grains of sand on all the
beaches of the earth but that shouldn't
stop us from trying to go into the
impossible
so
what are the takeaways again
torah means wisdom science means
knowledge they're not the same thing
can we prove god exists no that's not
what scientists do
we disprove things that don't exist
and the last lesson is to take away the
fact that abraham tried to do the
impossible
he knew it was impossible but when you
have something like an entity like god
telling you to do something you don't
say no
i think it's a valuable lesson that we
can all take away and it's not a
coincidence that my podcast is also
called into the impossible which you can
find when you do your homework
and visit both my
email list
to get updates from around the universe
that is cosmology astronomy theology
religion all sorts of events
uh when i start speaking around the
country again you'll be able to get in
touch with me i might come to a city
near you
and lastly where i keep my podcast into
the impossible where abraham would
surely go uh it is accessible on youtube
and anywhere you get your audio podcast
as well and with that i want to thank
everybody
and uh hope that you will all stay in
touch and i'm happy to take some
questions annie
all right yeah thank you so much dr
keating that was unbelievable uh thank
you for sharing your story
um and uh everything that you did with
us tonight
as i said in the chat
right after he ended uh the floor is
open
any questions uh
anyone may have on anything
that you're interested about learning
more about uh not competing
so yeah we'll just give it uh
maybe
a minute here um but
actually
i didn't get any questions in the q a
and i'm not in the chat yet so i'll give
people some time i'll kick it off with a
question i have
um
is
uh during your academic journey have you
experienced any
difficulties uh you know developing
these refraction
telescopes and what did you learn from
those challenges that
you've come across oh uh
did i ever experience any challenges
yeah uh so we've experienced basically
non-stop challenges in any of these
projects
whether it was getting the funding to do
it getting someone to believe in you i
had a mentor andrew lang
at caltech who believed in me in a way
that no scientists had ever believed in
me that you could actually measure the
early parts of the universe's evolution
and andrew was uh was a towering figure
in my life about 10 years older than me
kind of like an uncle
they would give me all sorts of advice
and uh in january
of
2010 when we should have been
celebrating the greatest heights
imaginable we had just deployed this
telescope to the south pole which was my
vision and his vision
he took his own life and nobody knows
why
and i write about him as kind of uh this
just just monumental loss for not just
me and cosmology but obviously for his
children his family and it's something i
could never really wrap my mind around
uh not that i was the you know the most
important consideration in his life but
just being so close to somebody who
believed in you they're really the first
true person i felt that way about
and uh than to lose them so that was
yeah devastating to me uh and then
moving losing out on certain
opportunities uh to to measure um and to
be a part of
uh uh different things but you get like
if i i point out in my book if i hadn't
been fired
uh from stanford which i thought was the
most challenging thing that ever
happened to me the worst thing that ever
happened to me
you know one of the greatest
institutions of higher learning in the
planet and i get fired the only time
i've ever been fired
and yet if that hadn't happened
i wouldn't have eventually moved to san
diego where i met my wife and had
children
um and been able to do everything else
i've been able to do in life
so uh since then so a lot of times you
think something's really bad but only
through the clarity of looking back
through the power of the telescope
the power of perspective that's what the
telescope means and
according to galileo was called a
perspective tube i got that perspective
but only through distance do you know
that what you thought was a challenge it
was actually a great gift
yeah thank you
uh yes we actually did get a few
questions coming in um the first one i
saw was from
rena
and the question is uh what are your
next steps to prove the big bang
oh that's my friend reena
uh so rina is uh is uh also a great
podcaster and she's married to a great
scientist
uh named zev uh so shout out to them uh
so the the simon's observatory will take
us to measure not only
the signals that get in the way the
contamination the systematic errors that
contaminate our measurement but we'll
also measure with deeper precision and
greater accuracy
the potential existence of these waves
of gravity which would then be evidence
for inflation which would then be
evidence for the big bang starting off
in a quantum fluctuation singularity and
also tie into something that i didn't
have time to speak about called the
multiverse um that would be maybe we'll
talk about that at a different event
perhaps
uh and then the next question
we have coming in is uh
what is the best advice that you have
for students who struggle with their
identities of being in stem and jewish
ah
well
um
i think that the most important thing to
to uh to work on in in
as a stem
aspiring stem professional i've never
seen it get in the way
in fact and stem is much much less
likely to face
uh some of the challenges that you face
and if you take judaic studies or
international relations so
i'm not sure why this question would be
uh really pertinent to to stem in that
you know stem is traditionally science
technology engineering and math
it's really focused on on
practical matters that don't involve
necessarily
a um a
confrontation
of your jewish ethnic identity cultural
identity or even religious identity
so um i've never found those in conflict
at all
um i would be much much less you know
optimistic
if i were studying you know something in
the humanities where it's often you know
there are there are a lot of challenges
to
um uh that come from things like uh like
the bds movement we don't have that
there there have been some attempts to
do that in the hard sciences luckily
they've been refuted in most ways
yeah
uh yeah i can definitely speak to that
as a student
as as well uh what you were saying
um
the next question we got is
from
uh
muba which is actually my mom um can you
provide an example of two of your
disagreements with dr
schroeder okay so hi mom happy mother's
day
uh
thank you for making andy
um so disagreements with schroeder so
again there is uh there are two
different philosophies one is to say
the torah and science are
what um what stephen j gould the late
great
atheist but jewish
historian of science at harvard said
were non-overlapping magisteria
in other words they are domains that are
self-contained and are completely
intact and wholly disparate from one
another that religion and science have
nothing to do with each other that is in
direct opposition to schroeder
and others who attempt to reconcile
a one-to-one correspondence between
statements and genesis
and statements in
in science
i
do not believe for myself that that is a
that that is the purpose and i think
gould agreed with this
that you cannot do specifically that you
cannot say
that one has a purpose and and without
opening up the possibility
that then okay so you're going to use
the torah
you're going to use science to prove
things in the torah well then what
prevents you from trying to say that the
torah is going to teach you things about
science
that to me is very perilous because
there are tons of things that aren't
addressed in the torah at all
dinosaurs evolution
um
and more or less the perspective and
this is not just me
these are i've had rabbis and and other
people
um who are scientifically erudite
including the former chairman of the
caltech math department barry simon
uh who's a torah you know very torah
true jew um as anyone who knows him
knows and uh and and there is a great
difficulty with some of the scientific
proofs quote unquote
so let me give you an example so
it doesn't he doesn't say this he's much
too brilliant to say this but schroeder
said something like the universe will
never um uh accelerate it will never get
the universe expanding but the expansion
will never increase with time it
actually doesn't even mention it in this
in his book from 1996 why
because we didn't know that the universe
is accelerating or expanding that
completely changes the dynamics not only
of our future but of how the first few
days
behaved
and and so we cannot walk we can't trust
to the precision that he's trying to
wedge together we cannot trust
that scientifically to be accurate when
when he wrote his book we didn't know
anything about this mysterious force
which dominates the amount of energy and
matter and energy in our universe
causing it to accelerate
and so all the more so can we not use
the torah itself i mean you have to say
even you might love schroeder i know
many of you do
but you can't say that he's superior to
moses
i don't care how much you love him and
so moses is silent on this right and and
there are many statements that are um
troubling if you think of the torah as a
science book and so i say again torah
means wisdom it means what you teach to
your children this torah
i don't teach my children a brief
history of time by stephen hawking she
hawking had a lot of problems as a
parent as a husband i don't get into it
but i don't use him to teach my kids
wisdom i use them to teach him knowledge
knowledge by definition is meant to be
eventually refuted torah is meant never
to be refuted so if you try to wedge
something in too closely it could be
like saying the earth is spherical
when in reality better that we know
science will know that that's not true
i'm not saying don't read it i'm not
saying i don't respect the person i'm
just saying there is a great deal of
controversy among scientists about it
his his way of interpreting it
yeah
uh yeah great response i think uh just
to be respectful of your time
everyone's time it's on i think we'll uh
wrap it up you wanted me to do this one
last question that we had your time
yeah
okay yeah so we'll wrap it up with this
last question here from chad
and it is can the formation of mass be
seen as a result of inflation
or expansion
oh
um
no so mass doesn't have to do with
inflation in mass we think about as
the formation or conservation
of energy in cosmology there is no
conservation of mass
in physics or in cosmology you can
create mass
from pure energy
and some say that the universe itself
was created from pure energy
and that has a context in religion but
it also has a context in what's called
quantum field theory
that you can
play certain
roles and quantum mechanics that then
can allow you to borrow energy
on very brief time scales such as those
that prevailed at the beginning of the
universe and that could actually be used
in a sense to instantiate matter which
has mass so no we can't um the the the
fields are allied and concomitant that
if you did have inflation it would
explain what powered and propelled the
big bang to expand but no you can't get
directly
the um there's no current that doesn't
mean there never will be but there's no
current mechanism from pure inflation to
get pure mass
that's a very sophisticated question
though
amazing all right and with that i think
we will wrap up today's talk uh again
thank you so much um for
uh speaking dr keating and for all the
support uh from all the other jewish
leaders in our community roberto
lisa and karen thank you so much for
being here today and thank you to
everyone that stayed on through the the
entire talk uh it was great having you
hope you all learned something new today
um as i strive to do every day myself
and yeah with that have a good night
thank you andy thank you dr keating
thank you lisa thank you karen
happy jewish american heritage month
everyone
yeah thank you guys
thank you so much
bye